Welcome to the stream.
Welcome!
Oh.
Okay, nice thing.
Oh, yes.
I have a mouth.
Mouth.
Okay, okay.
Good, good.
I can do it.
Open your mouth.
Yeah, yeah.
Ah.
Hello!
Oh, my God.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh!
Everybody, please say hello to Ayami Sensei!
Yay!
Hello!
Hello.
You need my introduce?
Oh.
Yes, please introduce yourself.
Oh, okay.
Studying English yesterday.
Okay.
Hi, hi, hi.
Hi, hi.
My name is Ayami.
Yes, Ayami.
I'm an illustrator and VTuber.
Yes, you know me.
Thank you.
And thank you so much for giving me this collaboration.
Thank you inviting.
And my hobby...
Sorry, I'm sorry.
Social distance.
Please, social distance.
Yes, I'm sorry.
And my hobby is stocking mint, Twitter and stream.
And my favorite type of girl is...
Yes, mint, yes, yes.
And I'm not good at English.
Sorry, sorry, but try using English today.
Yoroshiko negaishimaas!
How about my English?
Oh my God, perfect.
Oh, yes.
Thank you, thank you.
Sometimes, oh, one year old English.
I'm sorry.
Oh, thank you.
But that's charm point.
Charm point.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Charming Ayami, okay.
Thank you.
So, this weekend, Ayami Sensei will be coming to America.
Where is America?
Wow.
Too far.
You can swim.
Uh, too far.
Uh, uh, tired.
Because I'm too old, 100 years old and I cannot swim in.
Uh, using a plane, a flight.
Uh, too, too far.
But, but, but, but, uh, I have been to Hawaii.
Oh, really?
Oh, family trip.
But I have never been to the real United States.
Are you nervous?
Yeah, what is real USA?
Real USA.
Today we will learn real USA.
Yeah.
That is real.
Really, really, really,
stay america where are you me i'm in america real america uh
real uh you in japan isn't it isn't it because when iami uh
contact to you and message i think you always uh ah uh sorry
i i i'm now in japan you always saying Oh, again?
Again in Japan?
Ah, okay.
Ah, I mean think about Mint is not stay or live in America.
She, I think you live Japan almost.
My feeling is that and you live in America.
in my heart.
I love you.
I live in your closet.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ah, no.
No!
No, no, no.
Oh, I'm afraid it's a.
Wow.
Oh, oh, uh, so the ghost, I'm always close.
Oh, yeah.
I understand, I understand your ghost.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh, scary.
I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm scary ghost.
No, no, no.
If you feel cold, I, I, it's me.
Oh, I heard that some movie.
Oh, oh.
Some movie and under the bed and getting cold.
Yeah.
That is me.
That is.
Oh, yeah.
Oh,
you guys, every time it's so cold, I think, because me and
two always beside you.
So you got to go.
Heat tech.
We are in heat tech.
But in summer, it's so great.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Already hot?
Yeah, well, if it's hot, I can make you cool.
Oh.
really good yeah yeah yeah see how about winter oh um it's
okay sometimes it's like uh eating ice cream in winter oh
yeah yeah i understand yeah ice cream is always good with
cold time hot time every time is good uh there is you need
to okay yeah yeah uh Oh, what?
This is our first...
Oh yeah!
Our first collaboration stream.
But my feeling is something weird because...
We... We... We... We two...
Clothes?
Really?
I think it's normal maybe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you know... Do you know the word Deja?
Dejabu?
Yes, I know.
I know that.
I talked to you first time.
I want to collaboration with you, Mint.
That time I'm saying to you, I want to play that game.
Oh!
Switch game.
That is almost deja vu isn't it oh yes it's a good english
deja vu maybe we should play a game next time okay okay
something scary but yes we can do it something scary yeah
because i'm not good at game playing game oh and i saw you
last two stream or you you playing six hours Are you okay?
But it's normal.
It's normal.
Ah, okay.
Six hour.
Are you okay?
Oh, yes, yes.
I understand.
Yeah, see, they say together strong.
Push, push.
Already?
You, your hand is so cold and I think you are not good
control, maybe.
What?
Freezing hand and not good control, bad game.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, nothing, sorry, sorry.
You say I'm bad again?
Wait, no, sorry, sorry.
No, no, no, no, no, no, I don't know English, sorry, sorry.
I think you know!
Just love you forever.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, everyone, this time is my first visit.
We are real...
America.
We are USA.
Yeah.
What is different?
USA and US.
Oh, the same.
Huh?
USA or the same?
And America is three is everything.
Three are same.
America, USA, US is same.
It's just a shorter.
Ah, okay.
Sometimes, because USA...
Okay, it's a...
Uh...
Ah, I know that means United States of America.
Wow, that's a great American!
Oh my god.
Let's read that out.
Uh, Great America!
Yeah!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm studying.
Oh, yes.
Tensai.
So, yeah.
This time I'm busy to real America first time.
And you mean to, you have, have you ever been to Chicago?
I have.
Oh, really?
Yeah, I've gone to Anime Central.
Anime Central.
Yeah.
I'm already, what time?
One time, two times?
10 times?
No, no, no.
Maybe maybe only two times.
Oh, really?
How about that that that that that event?
I want to know the mood that how many people so hot?
Oh, so many people.
So many people.
Really?
Yeah, so many.
I think maybe your space, your booth will have a line.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I think...
No, no, no, no one coming!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Everybody?
Because always, I know because always YouTube comments and
Twitter, everyone's saying, I will go your space.
I will go to your booth.
But no one, no one come.
Don't call me.
No, come!
Don't call me!
Hold me!
Really?
Oh really?
Oh, okay.
Oh, it's...
It's...
Thanks.
Oh, it's so, it's so cold.
But even at Komike, your line was so long.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean...
I mean, I'm...
That time, I mean, find, found...
meet...
That line.
I'm really shocked because I saw Ryan and oh who is who is
she?
Oh no her!
Why are you standing line?
Because I want to be a normal fan.
Oh I know I know but but but you're.
you you mint uh i know you you are my friend that is really
happy but i think i mean always think about i amy and mint
is friends and i i want just to you you uh walk my space
walk in my space and hi amy that is my dream why you always
standing and waiting i i mean really i'm really that time
I'm really feeling so long distance.
Really?
Me too.
Don't think about we are friends maybe.
And she waiting forever.
And I'm already worried and sad.
No.
And I'm really worried because.
Because.
My worry is, reason is.
You are waiting in that line.
I think some people, Jettai, know you.
No, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, you.
Jettai, Jettai.
No, no, no.
Absolutely.
Every, the line people, oh, oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, mint, mint here.
No, no, no.
Oh, and my, and my fans, my illustration fans and my virtual
fans, confused because you're so cute and my fans want to
cheating on you.
Wow, really cute.
Oh, cheating.
Go, go, cheating.
Go, go.
I don't want you, you waiting line, please.
Please, next time, please.
Don't do that.
Don't, don't, don't, okay.
Don't do that, please.
think it's rude if i walk if i don't wait if i would hi
ayami sensei uh who is it who is it oh my i think my comic
staff think about oh ayami have uh another country friends
wow wow okay worldwide wow wow I'm jealous.
Oh, that is me.
Oh, foreigners!
My staff think about that.
Oh, I mean, really popular maybe.
But, but America event is really first time and I'm really
nervous because this time I'm bringing my books and my
posters and something something but if they left i think uh
burn front of convention center burning everything burning
because because heavy heavy too heavy and i mean campfire my
goods and my books and uh and i think that time more people
come to my space oh wow what is that uh campfire What is
that?
Campfire?
Everyone interested in campfire?
Not my artist Ellie.
I think maybe not interested.
I think they'll be terrified.
I think they'll...
Ah, fire!
And they'll run away.
Something weird, the Asian people in there, she burning
everything.
Okay.
Everyone, and I think another people say, oh, she's crazy.
Actually, Sensei, the, the books you're bringing.
Bring?
Yeah.
I mean studying USA role and a w row because i don't want to
arrest am i drawing to read and if maybe i'm arrested and
i'm really scary i'm really scary and this time display
illustration is my manager saying pure illustration he's
saying that and i'm choosing my illustrations and first time
i'm sending 10 illustrations and my manager saying uh please
uh pure illustration please select pure illustration you
you're wrong you're wrong i mean wrong your your brain suck
oh wake up and i mean huh and i mean sending uh again uh
another 10 10 illustration and my manager uh give up i am
and he choosing my illustration and please uh please send a
deaf psd file he say and i mean uh three times this time i'm
excited my pure illustration and i'm really shocked because
i think i think my illustration is not to read i think
really Yeah.
And this, this, um, right, um, that poster, the poster is
pure,
all poster, poster, poster, sure, yeah, so that, yeah,
that is all my cover illustration my books color cover
illustration is something danger but uh poster is i think
that is pure i think that is five years old buying is okay
but my books uh please uh take your uh id card i'm checking
your age you 20 okay oh what years is okay 18 18 18.
oh okay i'm studying 18 or 18 yeah 18 day 18 is a university
university yeah college college people yes yes ah okay okay
okay i'm checking your id bring your id she'll check your
address she'll stalk you address in there yes
want to know a good address some rich people rich people
address i i want to i'm i'm i mean uh remember that and uh
some guys uh good address i mean uh would you marry me would
you marry me i want to live uh usa forever please so
boyfriends if you if you are rich
Leave your address with Ayami-sensei.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, thank you.
I need fast internet, please.
Thank you.
Isn't it fast in Japan?
Yeah, but I don't know.
How about USA internet?
It's good?
It depends somewhere.
Sometimes it's slow.
Sorry, Japan too.
Internet.
slower slower than japan um but i don't know about maybe not
america maybe maybe not america hi uh uh uh uh uh uh uh yeah
yeah that's scary scary aren't you oh yeah yeah yeah i mean
to me to me i um please please tell me about something you
eat your experience in the u.s or chicago what is good what
is good i want to i want to buy i want to buy i want to buy
gun okay okay that is my dream i'll tell i want to go i'll
show you where to go buy a gun Can I buy?
Can I buy?
I really want to go.
Please marry me.
Please marry me, everyone.
I want to go.
I want to go really.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Because my head, my brain, my thinking is America is freedom
and gone.
It's true.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I'm so...
news sometimes or is that that topic is some freedom thing
now something some that topic or a gun and I I'm really
curious gun but I I mean one time just one time shoot oh oh
shooting range gun yes yes a small gun but I need oh really
shotgun shotgun
Shotgun and I want to hunting power I think you who Mary I
am you're already American.
I think
You're already American.
She's hunting boars you guys.
I'm really happy.
Yeah, I mean talk to everyone and talk to me this time I
mean I mean go Chicago but truly I think I mean go go Texas
maybe I mean I mean buying guns maybe at the booth you can
have left side left side book right side poster middle
marriage certificate
Good idea!
I love it!
It can be an auction.
Oh, really good idea.
I will try.
Like something, movie, I saw movie, some...
How, where was it?
Las Vegas, drinking alcohol and Mary and divorce?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
In Las Vegas Because you can get married very quickly.
Yeah, yeah.
When I'm in child time, I saw American movie and I think
about, wow, really amazing.
Okay.
Wow, so fast.
Wow.
That is real freedom.
Just did.
Okay, next convention, not Chicago.
Go to Las Vegas.
Yeah, Las Vegas?
Oh yeah, okay.
That is a good idea.
Woohoo!
Oh, no, no, no.
But I really want to go first.
is next is Texas Texas has no event, isn't it?
No, they have event.
They have event?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
And that event, everyone bring their gun.
No, no, no.
Maybe, I don't know.
I think everyone's inside pocket inside pocket, everyone has
gun, isn't it?
or food?
Food?
Hot dog?
Okay, I see.
I see.
I don't know.
Oh, sorry.
Hi.
Oh, so, no.
Please tell me what is good.
Discord.
What is good food or some experience?
Please recommend some tasting.
In Chicago.
Mm-hmm.
Chicago maybe pizza.
Oh, pizza.
So deep, deep dish.
Deep dish.
Oh, hot dogs.
Yeah, hot dogs.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Deep dish pizza is yummy.
Really yummy.
Everyone's saying yummy.
Really, really yummy.
This is really yummy.
I think...
I've...
...
How dare you?
You're really bad girl.
What?
Shut up.
Don't you.
Sorry.
Really?
So, then, then, then, what did you eat?
What did you eat before?
Yeah, I went to the event...
event...
...event...
There was a German restaurant close to the convention center
when we went there.
Beer, sausage.
Some meat.
They dance on the tables.
Why?
I don't know.
Dance everyone or...
You dancing too?
No.
Why?
You like dancing.
Sometimes.
Ah, are you?
Yeah, before the stream we talk about your dancing.
Really good.
I'm really, I like your dancing.
Too cute.
No!
I love you forever, yes.
Oh, this time, this time?
You...
You!
You dancing?
Oh, you...
Uh, uh, uh, yeah, uh, uh, uh, you...
Mint, you...
Or...
Not...
Dancing stream yet?
No.
I have no 3D.
Oh!
Make it!
Oh, can I borrow, uh...
I can borrow my modem.
Oh!
I've become inside.
Ah, Yami Sensei.
Yeah, yeah.
Push, push.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Uh, wow.
Oh my god, it's so big, heavy!
Oh my god!
But it's good!
Your... your opiates good size now.
Now, uh...
Really good.
A little smaller.
It's fake size.
It's a good bra.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, I understand, yeah.
How amazing bra.
That you buying that, your bra in America or where are you
buying?
In America, the big size, yeah.
Oh, I want to buy two same things.
Okay, you don't need it, I think.
I want, I need because I want more, more bigger.
Oh.
But, means, you know, I'm 100 years old human and my opiate.
Not big.
Not big, just wrong.
That's okay.
I think maybe also your boyfriend loves that too.
Boyfriends love that too.
Boyfriend, you like that too, right?
Thank you.
Long boobs.
The long boob is good.
Really?
How long is okay?
Really long.
Maybe?
Almost to my knee.
They reach.
They reach almost my knees.
Maybe.
I can't tell.
You have a really good bra.
Yes, this time I'm shopping my bra.
Yes.
I learned something.
Pizza.
Pizza and the German food and I really want to know you
tried and really eat food.
I want to know what is good.
Chat what is good?
Everything same one plate?
Yes!
Ah!
That is good!
That's good!
Smoke the meat?
Oh, that's a barbecue.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah.
Taco!
Taco?
Mexican food?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
American and Mexico Japanese kikou, and Japanese is very
different.
Really?
So, Taco Bell, how about Taco Bell?
Taco Bell?
Well, it's about the same.
It's like the same.
Oh, the same?
Oh, yeah.
So, yeah.
And taco Bell, it's different, it's different.
Different, no, not different.
What is different?
Smell or taste?
Taste or size?
Taste?
More deep or something different to taste?
Maybe.
Real...
Real Mexican food is better.
Real.
But...
Taco Bell is real, not real.
But America is not Mexico, just nearby.
Near, just near.
How, how, guys, how people can eat real Mexico food?
Maybe not Taco Bell.
If it's not Taco Bell, it's okay maybe.
Oh, okay.
Taco Bell, Taco Bell, Taco Bell.
Taco Bell, yummy.
Yeah, go to Mexico.
You can have a read.
Oh, that is a good idea.
Mexico, Mexico.
Mexico.
Okay, I understand.
Of course.
Well, sometimes I'm watching America TV show.
I think that time...
I mean,
like, you know, Dexter.
Dexter, you know?
Yeah, Dexter, you know?
Yeah, the serial killer.
Oh, okay.
That's why you think...
You think like...
Hi, Dexter.
Dexter, co-workers, I think, I remember Mexican, Mexican
people, many, and they using Mexico, Spanish?
Oh yeah, Spanish.
And they saying, say to Dexter, you're studying Spanish.
So, so, Spanish, just, Dexter for Dexter.
That's so developing.
And then so then, who for me, I had this Taco Bell
something.
Oh, yeah!
So I went, kind of like, so, the kind of thing that the
people is like this, or that kind of thing...
and like that kind of thing kind of So it's a little
different.
It's a little different, pretty different.
To my my image, Mexico people is in, the...
So different.
Different?
Why different?
Sorry.
Sorry boy.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Gato.
No.
I love.
Oh, I love you.
Precious mint.
I love.
Oh, Teamo!
I'm studying a little and now remember Preciosa and Gracias,
Gracias and Nobio, Nobia, because I'm talking to my
boyfriend and Nobio, Nobia.
Oh, typical, typical.
And yeah, I'm studying Dexter's, Mexico people is different.
Okay, I understand.
Maybe it's different.
I've never seen Dexter, but I think maybe it's a little
different.
Why no watching?
You ghost.
Everyone kill.
Everyone dead.
Inside the teddy fish.
Good, good.
Yeah, good.
Me too, you saw?
You saw?
You have been...
So, N-C-I-S.
Oh, yes, yes, yes!
Yeah, I've seen!
Yeah, I've seen, I've seen.
Oh, I mean, oh, she, I mean, like, gifts.
Oh, really?
Oh, yeah.
Odisha.
Because I'm 100 years old, and gifts is too young.
Ah.
Too, uh, Demi.
Demi, I like a young guy, and I like gifts.
So, wait.
Sure, and NCIS.
I think it's a little...
Atama, are you okay?
But sometimes, sometimes, I mean, watching that, there are
some teenagers, something, something.
Rumor, rumor, rumor, rumor.
Rumor, rumor.
Rumor, rumor, rumor.
Rumor.
a rumor some high school story and uh some uh some called
dad and why is he dead oh gossip girl no no no no no no no
oh no oh sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
I see.
Sorry, sorry.
Different title.
I've seen it too.
I've seen you.
Yes, yes, yeah, yeah.
You saw that?
Yes.
Oh, too, too sad story.
Yeah, so sad.
Yeah, I mean, saw that.
I mean, feeling is complicated because, I mean, cannot
understand teenager because I'm 100.
What are...
What they are, something, something.
Oh, I got really shocked.
Too young.
This is American TV show?
I think so.
Oh, I think so.
Yeah.
Do you watch a lot of American TV show?
Sometimes, sometimes because my parents think about when I'm
watching some English TV show They, my parents think about,
oh, I am studying.
You understand?
Oh, they think about, oh, I'm studying.
Oh, good girl, good girl.
Oh, yes, yes.
And I mean, always watching the Conan show.
SNL, something, something.
And I mean, always, oh, yes, yes, I'm studying English.
I'm studying English!
Oh my god.
Good student.
No, no, no.
Just, I mean always heard studying something bad word.
You don't know any bad words.
You're pure Sensei.
Yeah, yeah, I'm pure.
Yeah, I'm pure.
Because I I never saying someone to someone like some f word
because i mean never being google america and i i mean no
chance to saying to say f word oh you could say it now no
yeah no yeah
Oh, yeah, more time.
Oh, uh, uh, Is
it correct?
Yeah, it's powerful.
Sorry, sorry, you can like it.
I like you.
Just mean to hate you guys.
I mean, loves you, yes.
But for the stream, when you guys were crying, we were...
Don't cry.
Yeah, we were talking about it.
Yeah, but I mean, uh, I mean, I mean, think about What do I
mean to cinder?
Cinder!
No, no, no.
No, I mean to just cinder.
Don't worry, it means always love you, love your you guys.
I don't know.
I don't know, please try this.
No.
Yeah, yeah, already, oh, yeah, yeah, true, true, true.
Yeah, true, true.
Yeah, so that's it.
Taco, like.
Taco, shift.
Wait, no, snack, snack?
Snack?
Oh, potato chip...
Oh, I can't have carbonation.
Already what you eat.
No soup.
I want to something, dirty things, dirty, salty, sweet, high
calorie.
Yeah.
Do you know, do you know kettle chips?
Huh?
Kettle chips.
Kettle chips?
Yeah, yeah.
What make?
What do you think make?
Uh, I don't know.
Kettle chips.
Kettle chips?
What?
Kettle chip is kind of potato chip?
Yes!
Yeah, kind of potato chip.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're a little more crunchy.
Oh, really?
Yeah, yeah.
I like crunchy.
They're so yummy.
Cooked in a kettle.
Oh, how taste is good.
Something salt, bacon, something.
Honey, something.
Oh, have you tried sea salt and vinegar?
Oh yes I mean tried that using lace oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
that is so yummy Oh almost a similar taste and crunchy maybe
oh this taste is same but crunchy oh you should go to you
should see if they will take you to target oh target okay i
think about uh i mean to send a box to me inside okay i'll
send the box i'll send you okay okay oh so so sweet yes yes
uh you you go i mean you i think because uh Oh,
what do you say?
Oh, what do you say?
Oh, I know Target.
Yes, I have money, yes.
I have a credit card, yes.
I can buy, yes.
I can buy myself, yes.
No, I'll buy for you, I'll buy for you.
Yeah, no, no, no, it's okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can.
I just need some money exchange.
Just, this is too high.
Dollar is too high.
And it's very cheap.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
My dream is, I mean, exchange $1.
Mm-hmm.
$1.
$100?
Now $150?
$150?
Yeah, wow.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, steal money.
Mint wallet.
And I'm changing 100 bucks.
And $1,000.
Wow.
50% I got money.
Yes!
Yeah.
really happy death and i really want to die okay this one
you don't have to steal i'll give you my money oh really
yeah how how many how many how many how many money you can
however however
in my wallet i have million million three dollars million
three three $3.
Hey guys!
You guys, what are you doing?
I mean to have just $3.
What?
What happened?
You guys, go go!
Spend money!
No, they're saving their money for you at Anime Central.
Ah!
So you're good.
Oh, don't use money money bring money to my space don't
super chat don't super chat
don't super chat i think every guy's uh oh i am crazy think
about this no they love you right everybody
Say yes.
Yes.
I'm waiting.
Is there anything you want to do in America?
Oh, this time I really want to go to their Chicago Art
Museum.
Oh, I really want to go there and I want to see that.
Goh.
Goh is English.
Oh!
Golf?
Golf!
Goh!
I'm trying to get a golf?
Golf?
Don't say the Super chick!
Oh my god.
Vincent van Gogh.
Eh?
Oh, van Gogh!
Bango!
Bango?
Not ban?
Banjano?
Bango?
English.
English difficult.
Vincent Bango.
Okay.
Vincent Bango drawing his room picture in Chicago Museum.
Oh, really?
Oh, and I want to go to there and I'm staying there.
that and the rest I mean I mean live forever USA jail no
happy life that's how you can live in America in jail yes
yeah too cold maybe that there is too cold maybe maybe in
jail in jail it's too cold I think a good that is not bad I
think not bad yeah Okay, okay.
Meet.
We talk almost one hour, I cannot believe.
Today's stream is, what is good American food or something,
something?
That is not main topic.
It's not the main.
Yeah, yeah.
Main topic.
What are you?
What are we doing?
I'm confused.
I'm sorry.
But everybody must see, look.
Everybody look at the drawing.
what Ayami-sensei is bringing to Anime Central.
Ah, I really thank you.
Make sure you buy everything so she doesn't burn it in front
of the convention.
Yeah.
Well, if you guys don't need a campfire, buy it.
Buy it, please.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah, please.
Wait.
Please buy it.
Maybe...
Maybe this is a strange question.
But out of these books, Sensei, what is your recommendation?
Oh, that is...
That is really difficult question.
But this time, I make an English version book.
Everything transferred...
that uh
there is a read book id card id card check yeah i mean
drawing my original character may and may do some read
things and that book i mean transfer english And I think
that is first recommend.
Second book is...
That is really sad story.
I don't know.
Talk about that.
But...
Just one week ago, I mean, make new book.
Yo-Zoramel Memory.
Yeah.
My third, whichever third book.
That is recommend too.
And...
Uh, I recommend the poster, uh, yes, yes, something that
you're watching then on that.
And, uh, I mean, uh, hi, hi, yes, green, green poster.
I mean, recommend.
Ah, go to the engine, go to the, I mean, recommend
everything.
Hi, bye!
Thank you!
I want to know about you.
About me.
Talk to you.
Yes.
I want to know me too.
Everything.
Because, because...
You saying...
You saying your friends?
Maybe?
Not yet.
That, that, that, that.
Not yet?
Really?
Yeah.
Okay, the first announcement in Mint Channel.
Yes, yes.
Yeah, this time I mean do live drawing in anime, animal,
animal?
Anime Central, I mean do live drawing.
session and that time Ayami drawing mint so if you're going
to anime central at the live drawing panel can I drawing
mint yes
and I want to I really want to ask him I heard I understand
I understand you draw your concept sketching oh yes oh I
want to know which part is the point your design okay let's
check let's take a look yes oh it's me
what would my charm what would the point be
O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-D-O-O-O-O-O-O-I-O-O-D-O-D-O-O-O-D-O-D-O-D-O-D-O-D-O-DO-D-I-D-D-O,
okay.
Okay, you can go.
Ah, don't die.
Nice.
Me too.
What is true?
Hi, please teach me your everything.
Let's see, maybe I have my butt.
Yeah.
And also on my socks, there's chocolate.
chocolate oh yeah it's delicious oh can i read yeah yeah
what's dreamy okay okay okay please forgive me youtube
please we are pure we are pure yeah don't worry youtube
don't worry don't worry this is just this is nice about
introduction.
So just lick chocolate.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
And you can see, you can see my ribbon is also chocolate.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Really cute.
How you think about this design?
You want to be made first time and I'm really curious you
like mint chocolate oh I do but I don't know why I became
mint chocolate at first I was only mint and then I became
mint chocolate I don't know why I
love you
There's too...
Too...
So, what do I mean...
Because it's not like...
I've never eaten it.
Like, it's like...
There's a lot of...
This is really...
It's like...
Yeah, I guess.
And, of course, it's like this kind of thing.
Maybe it's too much for someone who's 100 years old.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
is too difficult to taste but not not dislike just to a
little not not good at not good yeah not good at not good
but someone buying to me but not paying my money but i can't
paying to you I love you.
I love you.
Yeah, I'm really, I mean, first time saw your design, I'm
really shocked color because mint color is, I think, really
good color because I mean, never think about using mint
color.
Really?
Using drawing.
And I mean, wow, there is really funny and interesting
color, I think.
This is good mint.
Good mint.
Okay, okay.
Because I never tried to using that color.
This time I'm using mint color.
I'm really excited.
A lot of mint.
Yeah.
You know what, you choosing mint color?
Just you like mint.
Yes, I like mint.
My idol Oshi, her color was mint.
So I became mint.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
Oh, so, so, so, so, so, so, so,
I want to know what's what what's mint mint is your favorite
part what part is your favorite your you like Where do you
like?
Where do you like?
Actually, I think my favorite part is my sleeves.
Sleeves?
Yes.
Do you like?
streaming time
the sleeves uh it's my live drawing it's an hour of live
drawing oh it's an hour live drawing so ah I can't draw
anything amazing but no it will be I like no I just want to
do my best and I think I want to what I think I'm drawing
upper body because just one hour sadly yeah one pose or
facial pose
I think I...
I...
Honestly, sometimes I think Mint, why you using your face
like that?
No, don't hear me?
Eh, don't.
I think you so, you just, I think you just cute, but you
using your face something, something ugly or something funny
and something so became...
like...
sometimes I think there is...
there is mint?
What the face?
what the...
what the face?
everything cute but I think...
so-so now that emoji like that, that comment that kind of...
Yes, yes, comments.
Because I'm thinking about cute girls or, how do you say, I
mean, I think about cute girls or, I mean, I think.
Oh, Minto-chan is a little more interesting, I use my face,
or I use my face, I'm not a gay-nine-nine-nine, you're a
gay-nine, I'm not a comedian.
I did comedy on me too.
Yes, yes.
It's because...
Maybe if you try to be cute, it's too much pressure.
Pressure is too much.
Why?
It's just cute.
It's not.
What?
It's kind of weird.
It's weird.
Are you looking?
Yeah.
What?
But it's funny, it's okay.
I like your humor.
But I mean sometimes, Ah, dead face.
But it's funny.
It's okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, I always think about, wow, Mint is really good
using your character and your resource.
And there is really, I think you have talent.
I love you forever.
Yes.
And what facial?
Oh, expression.
Expression.
something cute or wink or something
maybe maybe the chat can decide because they will be the
ones watching the picture watching you draw so chat what
kind of face would you like to see Ayami-sensei, draw with
me.
What?
No way.
No way?
That's a- Ahe-gao!
Don't- Oh, can I- Can I draw a-hae-gao me?
Can I?
Can I- Can I- Can I- Can you?
It's okay.
That's what you're doing, Ayami.
What are you doing, Ayami?
Sorry.
It's Japanese...
Japanese culture.
Not...
Oh, not reading things through term.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He calls it freedom.
Oh, USA freedom.
Freedom.
Yes, I believe.
What's good?
I thought maybe Smog?
Smog?
Can you do it?
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
The, my, like, this cat is so cute.
Very cute, cute.
Ah, cute, cute, cute.
Oh, doya, doya, gaw.
Oh, doya gaw?
Ehhh?
How's it?
How?
Uh...
I'm gonna...
...
Doya-Gaoh?
Doya-Goh and smog are two, I'm gonna say.
Whink or he's okay?
Maybe doya-gau?
Doya-gau?
Doya-gau-gau?
Doya-gau and smoke?
Doya-gau-gau and smoke?
Wink-gau-gau-gau?
Yeah.
What is good?
But...
Oh, I'm talking about mint using her face.
Or something different.
You can say it.
She's using her face every time everywhere.
Because I'm thinking about something.
I'm thinking about something.
Meade, meade.
You made.
Yes.
And something, the smug face is...
You made...
When you using smug face, The girl's... the girl's...
The girl's...
I'm like, when's the smug?
When's the... the face?
The face...
Oh, thank you.
I'm back again.
So, that's...
That's the difference.
Well, the time.
The time, the...
...oh, it's like that.
That's right, that's right.
Why I've been asking to you what facial is good?
Because just cute or just smiling is, I think you don't like
that.
So you, I think you like something funny things or
something.
Yeah, I want to know what is good.
Oh, maybe, maybe.
Yeah.
Yeah, I got it.
Oh, yes.
I...
I got it.
Okay.
Don't get arrested.
Okay, try, try.
Just face, just be not all bad.
Okay.
It's okay, I think Just the base is Freedom Freedom No, it's
too Freedom Just a freedom Yeah So, yeah Showing the Free
That's like Welcome Some Like Someone Like Like Like I was
To Yeah,
So I mean, this time first, yeah.
We are America.
America, yeah.
Yeah.
I think I mean naked and walk.
Work.
Why naked?
Oh, freedom.
Oh, no.
Maybe American needs to be more free okay don't try don't
try it and you mean to uh i'm sorry for all the patient
because just one hour drawing and uh i think i might only
draw uh You are...
That is okay.
Just no face, no face, just boom!
How about that?
Not bad.
It's good.
Freedom!
Yeah, freedom!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, everyone!
Oh, yeah, yes!
Everybody loves Ayami Sense, et al.
So you'll enjoy.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Uh, So anyway, so...
It's kind of, uh, minute's like to unhappy, Listen, hey,
like, that's something?
Stop that.
That, that, is there?
Oh, I'm sorry.
It's actually this.
It- Oh, actually.
Taki-makura Abara, Taki-makura Kaba.
Oh my god, that would be my honor.
Naked is okay?
I mean naked and bring naked me to Takimakura and walk
around the park.
How's that?
We are both naked.
We are okay.
Okay, it can be a fan meeting.
Naked in the park.
Oh, but I need everyone naked too.
Yeah, everybody naked too.
Naked, yeah, and we got party too.
We party naked in the park.
Yeah, and campfire too.
Oh, with your books.
Burn my books.
Burn my books and merch.
And your clothes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We are not cold, we are not cold.
No, no.
Meant not coming.
I think I'm busy at that time.
Sorry, sorry.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Really thank you design permission.
I can join you.
That is really exciting because this is first to join USA
event.
And first time I think about what drawing is good for USA
fans and I'm really think about so many things but I mean I
mean is really mean to use his big op-ed pen and I really
want to draw in you and I mean asking to you can I mean
drawing you that I mean to my feelings mean to
No, no, no, no, no.
Me too.
Huh?
Why?
I think she got scared.
No!
When I talk to, I want to drawing you opi.
No.
I think if my face...
Oh, quite.
But if my opi, it's okay.
Okay, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I'll just drawing opi.
Okay.
I think I please looking forward to my live drawing session.
I'm really scary because sometimes on streaming my channel,
I'm drawing live drawing, but that time no one show, no one
showing real IME.
But this time real IME sitting table and drawing.
It's a rare chance everybody, rare chance.
Chance naked, I am watching.
Oh no!
It's not.
Don't worry.
Will you be wearing...
Will you be naked?
I'm wearing panties, don't worry.
Only panties.
Only panties, don't worry.
And her new bra.
Yeah, yeah.
But I can hide using my obi, long obi.
I don't need panties, maybe.
You're my body.
Okay, good, good, good, good.
I think...
Maybe no one will come.
Wow.
So you got to match.
I'm wearing something.
Don't worry.
And really nervous.
And also please wear something too.
And I'm really scary because...
I'm really nervous and...
Maybe?
Asumi failed?
Failed?
Drawing?
Why?
Maybe?
Maybe.
Too nervous and my hand not moving, cannot move.
No moving and I mean...
So, so, so, so, so, so sorry.
No!
Session closed, so sorry, bye bye.
Everybody, I know everybody will say, Gumbare!
Hayami-san-san-san, you can do it!
Please cheer me all!
Yeah, don't cheer you on!
Right everybody?
I mean practice in airplane.
10 hour.
10 hour practice.
Please sleep.
And I want to draw in cute mint in anime center.
If you guys someone come anime center, please come and
please check.
Really, I am drawing.
Yes.
Meant, oppai.
Or.
Ahegau.
Or something.
It's a surprise.
Yeah, please check.
Will it be oppai?
Will it be ahegau?
It's a surprise.
After drawing, I mean arrest or not?
Please check.
That's the, that's the finale.
Wow, there is a, what is good finale?
The rest is a good finale.
There is a legendary finale.
Maybe a first time ever.
And then Sankai at the jail.
Oh,
so sorry.
But that is funny.
But don't worry guys.
I'm wearing some clothes.
And I'm enjoying cute mint.
Please looking forward and...
And...
Hey, Soledad!
When you're coming?
Japan?
June.
Oh, June?
Okay, I'm waiting.
You, maybe you bring my birthday present.
Yes.
Naked.
Ah, okay.
Naked, I mean, okay.
My birthday present.
Present.
A gun?
You want a gun?
Gun?
Can you bring to Japan?
I'll be arrested next.
Oh, me to arrest.
Oh.
We write a letter.
In jail.
I mean, American jail, me to Japan jail and we write letter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I really miss you.
I'm really miss you.
I wish I was eating candy.
I'm really too poor.
I'm really looking forward.
Oh yeah, June, you come in.
Do something.
Yummy, do you...
What kind of...
Wait, at Anime Central, are you accepting gifts?
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
What kind of candy?
What kind of...
Oh, I mean like...
Sour can...
Sour...
Me too, me too!
Sourgumi.
Oh, Sourgumi!
Sourgumi!
Yeah, yeah.
But, I mean, can eat everything almost.
And bring it everything.
Okay, bring everything!
Yeah, yeah, no trashy, no trashy.
Okay.
No trashy, okay.
And just bring...
Smart...
Just one...
Chupachup Chupachup Chupachup Chup Chupachup Oh Oh Oh Oh I'm
sorry I'm sorry Chupachup Uh Just one is really happy I am
Bring it Bring it Bring it I want to taste every Every taste
Everything Every kind of And bring Money Ah Dollar Doll,
please!
Okay, I mean it's also looking for a husband, so...
Boyfriends, line up.
Yeah, please.
Please showing your house.
Oh, yes!
If you get to autograph, you can show your house and how
much you make.
I think watching this stream, Mint fans and Ami fans think
about, wow, absolutely Ami crazy.
That's the best.
They went crazy.
Well, this time because I'm really...
Some high?
Just like, I mean, just the only girlfriend to my fans.
I think I'm going to go to USA.
My feeling is something free.
She's getting too excited, you guys.
Yeah, and get married or divorce or go to jail.
Everything is okay.
Yeah, experience this time.
It's American experience.
Yeah, that is really cool, I believe.
I will write some books, one book, America Experience title,
and I will write a book in jail, maybe.
Wow.
Not bad.
It will become a Netflix show.
Oh, maybe I can get money, maybe.
Oh, maybe.
Royalty, please.
Yeah.
Good idea.
Okay.
Then Min- Hi.
I guess Min- Min-ta-chan, yes.
And so- Min-ta-chan, min-ta-chan, Yeah, King-y-y.
Oh, it's about Friday.
Drawing after autograph session.
Ooh!
So first you have an autograph and then you're drawing?
Yeah, yeah.
And Saturday.
Saturday.
VTuber stream.
Ooh!
And Sunday.
Autograph session one more.
Ooh!
That is my schedule.
Come on, guys.
That's this guy.
You have a whole weekend with Ayami Sensei.
Yeah.
This time I'm really busy and my cat too sick.
He's really sick.
He needs surgery.
And my mom come to my Tokyo house and she take care to and
Kumachan when I'm going to go to America time.
And this time my heart is really not good.
upset Ayami because the best doctor saying maybe who dying
and I'm really crying every day
but strong strong mind Ayami yes we can do it and and I'm
cannot drawing this time mean to some goods or posters and
maybe next time I mean can uh chance to um join another or
chicago uh anime event yeah i i want to drawing mint and i
want to make mint goods and i want to make make naked mint
takimakura i got it loyalty loyalty loyalty loyalty it's my
treasure And I really want a chance to next time.
I hope that you have so much fun.
I'm so sorry about your cat, but I think you will have so
much fun and it will be a good distraction.
Yeah.
So, and you will have many, many fans who will be so excited
to see you.
I saw your autograph sessions.
Both of them were full.
Maybe some guy, some boyfriend.
Propose.
See, no, no, no, see, I mean.
And maybe...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Shoot, shoot, maybe.
The dead jacket, the wadi state jacket.
So, what is the jacket?
So, like, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
What is that?
Uh, no, uh, protect jacket.
Straight jacket.
Oh, yeah.
I need that because, uh, my boyfriend just showed Iami,
maybe.
Ah, no, no, no.
Yeah, I mean, so cute, everybody.
Oh, oh, no, oh, no, don't say that!
Yes!
Don't say that!
I said it!
It's very cute.
Yeah.
Um, last week, I'm in Akihabara.
Oh!
And Starbucks.
And I'm sitting, uh...
Same seat?
You sitting, sit.
English!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Okay, okay.
Uh, last week, Ayami Sensei went to Akihabara and we met
last time at a Starbucks and she sat in the seat that I sat
in.
I'm stalker, sorry.
Did you sniff it?
Yeah, absolutely.
Not so early.
Oh, mother.
Oh, good smell.
Good smell.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, yeah.
Yes, yes, good smell.
And I may drink, drink some, some, some mango smoothie.
It's the same drink, my old ashi.
Ah, I'm stalker.
It's okay, me too.
I stalked you to the cafe, to Ayami cafe.
I saw a yummy figure.
I was like, oh, oh, oh, pants are coming.
Don't do that.
Dabi.
Today, Shiro.
Ah, Shiro.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Sorry.
Hi.
Are you wearing panties?
Oh, yeah.
Thank you.
I really want to see you soon.
Yeah.
Soon.
When I come to Japan?
Yeah, I want to take showers with you.
Okay.
We go to onsen.
Oh, really?
We can.
Yeah.
So, so, so, so, so, so there are all, all the men both men
and all women all together.
What's her?
Oh, not.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no.
Well, no.
But, to, two, to, two.
Yes.
I'm sorry, you guys, uh, Mintu already Mine.
So sorry.
But then what about your boyfriend?
My boyfriend is boyfriend.
You girlfriend.
Oh, yes, yes.
Girlfriend, girlfriend take shower together.
Boyfriend, no touch, no touch.
I'm platonic.
I am platonic.
Platonic.
Yes, yes.
Don't touch, no touch, social distance.
Social distance, everybody.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, please.
Happy see your boyfriend.
Yeah, I see your boyfriend.
Boyfriend, not only.
But really important thing is not body, body, not body, I
think.
Mental, mental, emotional.
emotion love each other true truly is really important body
uh touchy and a rig something something uh that is just um
no no no no no no that's too simple that's too simple sorry
everybody oh yeah yeah sorry sorry i i'm waiting uh uh
nothing i'm waiting true through true true love Oh, true
luck.
And I finally found...
Where?
Here.
Oh, Chica.
Don't go, don't go.
Thank you.
It was very fun.
Yeah, really.
Thank you.
Thank you for inviting.
Oh, thank you.
And please love me into forever.
And please, a little like Ayami too.
And please looking forward Anime Central.
And please looking forward me to future too.
Thank you.
But she's mine.
Give up her.
Thank you.
Yomi, that's it!
Thank you for coming!
Koshio, thank you!
Thank you guys, thank you guys.
Me too, hates you, guys.
Get out of here.
This is our...
Yeah, yeah.
Get out.
Go away!
Go away.
Social distance.
Go home.
Yeah, go to Anime Central.
Yeah, I don't know.
Not here.
Anime Central.
Yeah, not here.
Wow, you're so cool.
Sexy.
Okay.
Oh, cool.
Wow.
Thank you everybody for watching!
Look forward to Ayami Sensei drawing me at Anime Central!
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited!
Yippee!
And please subscribe to Ayami's channel and follow on
Twitter and buy everything at Anime Central so that there's
no fire.
And are you eating my hair?
Ah, so sorry.
What?
Ah, mint taste, okay.
It's like a toothpaste.
Ah, I just...
Yes, some...
Some...
Ah, yeah, yeah, no, no, it's okay, okay.
Ah, because some...
Well, two years ago, I'm using...
Try to using some...
Ah, what is that name?
Call...
Starting C and something gate, like gate.
Oh, call gate.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Toothpaste, you know?
Yes, yes.
So, that time I'm using some mint to taste.
Oh, that is...
Not bad.
It's the same taste?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, good.
Make a shower.
Go away, take a shower.
Yeah, okay.
Brush, brush, brush.
Tooth.
Tooth, uh, brush your teeth.
Ah, brush your teeth.
Yeah.
And kiss each other.
You guys kiss each other.
Yeah, you guys kiss each other.
Not us.
Kiss each other.
No, no, no.
No, no.
I need packing time.
I want to go.
Come on, we have to leave.
Get out of here.
Yeah, get out of here.
Yeah, come on.
We're trying.
We're trying to...
We're busy.
Go, go away.
Yeah.
I'm really busy.
I'm packing and go go airport and I'm finally arrived.
Departure?
Departure is the start of the Chicago.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
Bye-bye.
What's mint?
Mother.
Okay, bye.
Bye.